not every rock band appreciated Rolling
Stone like Led Zeppelin had a real
problem with you guys yeah I mean you
know which is weird I'm sure in
retrospect you're like oh [ __ ] we didn't
get everyone right you know we didn't
know I mean Led Zeppelin arguably again
in the top 10 bands of all time right no
I'm not disagree I'm not I'm I'm you
know no I mean who are the other who are
the other nine well you got the Beatles
The Beatles the stones okay so the
ability you've got the Springsteen band
right you've got some session bands like
Booker T and the mg's okay Dire Straits
having three personal favorite of mine I
know where this is going by the way
what where is it going yeah you told me
well I know what you think is the 10th
grade fan
what what is your Palace Bon Jovi you
know what pisses me off about that I
show up in Cleveland today why Cleveland
I don't know maybe you can tell me but I
show up to the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame to induct John and the boys
who's not there John I mean and they say
oh Jan's not feeling well I go yeah is
not feeling well I feel worse than
whatever Rihanna's going through
I was so the person that you weren't
there I'm sorry I had broken my leg so
getting around at that time was really
difficult well the rumor was you were
dying everyone said John's dying I said
oh I should get in touch maybe but I'm
now mad at him that I'm at the Rock Hall
of Fame yeah everyone thought so and it
was John who was spreading it Bon Jovi
he himself I think so you know it was
interesting but it was also but then
after it was over I got started getting
calls like saying oh my God it's lucky
you were here Howard went off on you on
a stage and then even John Club said oh
I didn't tell him to say that you know
so I better listen to this so I got I
got a hold of it right away and it was
one of the funniest riffs that I heard
along I was flattered to death and I
knew you had a good sense of humor but
then I didn't hear from you and I
thought oh [ __ ] he's pissed off he
didn't like it he didn't like me making
jokes about him but then you wrote me
and you said no no I loved it and I was
like oh thank God he still has a sense
of humor that was great it was so funny
I cracked it I'm like people who are
you're part of citizens you know will
take offense for you very quickly at
some other things whereas look to be
celebrated by you at the hall of fame
was pretty cool